welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a full frame by frame
breakdown of every detail you missed in
Spider-Man across the spider-verse now
that the film is available in 4k digital
the hundreds of Animation details and
Easter eggs can now be found and what's
really great about these spider-verse
movies is that it's not just comic book
references it's a vast web of attention
to detail worked into this film by and
for lovers of filmmaking the history and
craft of Animation all of it filled with
soul that these animators wove into
these characters and into their worlds
now we've made a few videos breaking
down this movie already but here right
now is the definitive across the
spider-verse analysis brought to you by
folks who truly do go through these two
hour and 22 minute movies frame by frame
and I did a similar analysis for the
2018 Spider-Man into the spider-verse in
the Deep dive Channel subscribe to that
and all three of the channels of our
Network also sag after has informed us
that entertainment journalist like new
rockstars are allowed to continue
covering movies like this but we joined
these unions and call into the studios
and streamers to make a fair deal with
writers and with actors okay literally
nine seconds into the film you say the
word
color in the lower right corner
producers Phil Lord and Chris Miller
added the sound of a cough to the
opening seconds of the 2018 into the
spider-verse which was then a callback
to their previous film 2014-22 Jump
Street they just like the joke of one of
their cops being captured in the audio
but here it's not just the sound of a
cough it's the literal text word cough
they want us to see it what makes across
the spider-verse unique to the 2018 film
is that the animators lift the hood to
show us the themes of their work with
storyboard keyframes editors notes
background lines to make us appreciate
the effort and to invite us into this
story in progress from the dueling
protagonists When Stacy and Miguel
O'Hara that's right this sequel is less
of a Miles Morales story it's Gwen's
story of regret for not being a better
friend miles as Miguel O'Hara attempts
to hijack control and it enforced that
narrative through his prescribed Canon
defense the opening logos of Sony
Columbia Pictures and marveled all
glitch and on the Marvel one you can see
a miles tag from the 2018 film on his
name tags the Lord and Miller production
company logo fine mustaches with both of
these actual animators depicted in this
old-timey ad but listen closely here
yeah you heard a dolphin sound effect in
there a running joke from Lord and
Miller's Clone High that they also put
into the beginning of the 2018 film then
with a heavy Bell thud the approved by
the comics code Authority stamp which
was put on all comic book covers in the
1950s to reassure parrots that these
Comics wouldn't glorify crime or corrupt
their kids minds but the dark tone of
this stamp might be a clue that Miles
and Aaron of Earth 42 are not criminals
designed to corrupt our children they're
actually heroic Vigilantes trying to
fight the good fight against the
Sinister Six cartel of that Universe
concentric circles represent Gwen
Stacy's drumming for the Mary Jane's
band her first line is let's do things
differently this time like so
differently it's gone back to the way
the spider people would introduce
themselves in the Past film all right
let's do this one last time all right
people let's do this one last time all
right people let's start at the
beginning one last time but Gwen's voice
over here frames this whole opening
monologue as really her recruiting pitch
to the other spider Heroes to save miles
at the end of the movie She's expressing
regret here let's do things that
differently let's not screw up with
Miles this time that's why this opening
Montage shows both images of Gwen and
miles from the first movie and what is
to come in the second movie miles and
Gwen sitting upside down miles releasing
Gwen's web miles and Gwen and the web of
life and Destiny room the two of them on
the bullet train Gwen stuck in the go
home machine and more all of it is
really a prologue for the events to come
we are hearing Gwen later in this movie
talking to Peter p Parker Mayday
Spider-Man Noir spider ham Penny Hobie
Brown Victor and Margot after miles has
been stuck in Earth 42 because here she
says now he's on his own
not the only one and I think that other
one that Gwen is referring to might just
be yourself but also Earth 42 miles and
notice how in the flashback of Miles
dead spider number 42 includes a shot of
some tweezers picking it up which we
didn't see before because we are now
seeing the moment this dead spider was
recovered by Dr Jonathan own in 1610. we
see the selfie Gwen and Miles took that
she had on her phone at the end of the
2018 film from the Hudson Valley bus you
can see Peter B Parker's legs
outstretched behind them but it shakes
here because we later see this is inside
of her drum so she is literally drumming
her guilt this percussion on her friend
Gwen wears a smashing Hearts shirt 1989
tour and her bandmates call her Def
Leppard a reference to the Band Death
Leopard and a pun calling her def d e a
f from her drumming which is a specific
reference to Gwen's very first comic
introduction in 2014 in the comics and
here in Earth 65 the Mary Janes consists
of lead singer Mary Jane Watson Gloria
Grant on guitar and Betty Brandt on Keys
Gloria and Betty both being employees of
The Daily Bugle so Gwen's Universe of
Earth 65 was given a watercolor
aesthetic that just looks amazing with
pastel colors of pink and blue and white
which yes are the colors of the trans
flag which Gwen has as a poster in her
bedroom Gwen says in this line of work
you always wind up with solo act I love
how the animators briefly put Gwen in
her suit just for the phrase in this
line of work because that's what she's
wearing when she's working in the window
behind her you can see miles's face but
in the other window across the subway
car is her memory of Earth 65 Peter
Parker voiced in this movie by Jack
Quaid and these flashbacks Gwen has
longer hair because this is before miles
stuck his hand to her head and she had
to shave it Quinn and Peter and their
parents pray before dinner in this rapid
flicker Montage one of Peter's shirts is
a green white and purple polo that he
wears in the 90s animated series another
one shows Peter in a lizard costume as
he will become the lizard meanwhile
Gwen's Halloween costume is the VLC
Media Player app and they are all eating
bagels which is the critical food that
led to the spot and recurs throughout
this movie as a symbol of the Multiverse
something that this movie shares with
everything everywhere all at once it's
also worth pointing out that in these
shots holding May's hand is Uncle Ben
because he is still alive in this
reality and Peter's bully in this
reality is not Flash Thompson it is Ned
leads and we get another sick transition
Gwen subway car opens to a prom night
memory and as we go from her shorter
hair and her Street closed captioning
not available
Stacy leads the Manhunt for Spider Woman
who is she why won't she show her yeah
JK Simmons voice is Triple J here and so
far he seems to have played Jameson in
every single film reality that we've
seen now Gwen is tinted blue in this
pink world as when you feel depressed it
can feel like everyone else is having a
bubble gum day except you her father
George Stacy wears a Visions Academy
Gymnastics sweatshirt showing that he's
such a supportive dad and while her
whole room is blue to match her when she
hugs her dad the watercolor spreads the
warm fuchsia color outward because just
a simple hug really can change your
entire world so George arrives at the
Guggenheim and says
explain to me how a guy with a 40-foot
wingspan just waltzed into the
Guggenheim unnoticed yeah Yuri is Yuri
Watanabe a cop introduced in The Amazing
Spider-Man comics who turns into the
villain wraith and she kind of hints at
that here hey it's New York everyone's
got their thing but Gwen webs them up
how's the Manhunt for me going yeah she
lowers her voice there just like miles
always lowers his voice with his cop
father an alternate universe vulture is
voiced by yorma tacon attacking brought
to this universe by the collider
incident in the 2018 film this vulture
is a from an Italian Renaissance
Universe depicted in discolored
parchment in the style of Leonardo da
Vinci's sketches his attacks often have
Da Vinci styled notes scribbled beside
them because Da Vinci always showed his
work and I just realized that he wears a
traditional Italian Comedia Del Arte
mask that are known for these huge
hooked noses and when he lowers over his
armored mask it is a plague doctor mask
which looks like a bird beak it's just
incredibly clever character design that
works on multiple levels now he has
landed in front of the Jeff Coons
retrospective exhibit which is a real
exhibit at the Guggenheim with these
balloon animal figures made from
stainless steel and a Renaissance artist
like him would totally be disgusted with
postmodernism so the artist working on
this movie used the action to teach us a
little bit about Art and Design I mean
it's more of a meta commentary on what
we call Art but it's it's just like how
these movies require the artist making
them to rethink the way film animation
could even work vulture said
which translates to bye girl on the
screen and she's rescued by Miguel
O'Hara voiced by Oscar Isaac you're the
blue panther no the Caped blue sailor
yes of course references to the Black
Panther into Batman the cape Crusader
but also dark Garfield as in dark Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man like a Spider-Man
who wouldn't care if Gwen Stacy dies
notice how the edges of Miguel's body
have these hatch lines which make his
shoulders and Corners look sharper and
more Barbed someone you don't want to
give a hug but also a futuristic work in
progress never complete never good
enough his comic book lands on the same
stack that we ended the 2018 film with
you see Miles Morales Gwen Stacy spider
ham Spiderman Wars comics so all these
new heroes are building on the stack
cumulatively throughout this film series
and these hatchlines now are more
pronounced as Miguel begins to explain
his function you can see blue lines
which is what animators and artists use
when they're sketching out the
dimensions of their characters lines
that are later erased but Miguel also
has to has to show his work to prove
himself this shot of him here is one of
the animation changes they made from
theatrical to digital Miguel now moves
close to the camera while his background
showing Ben Reilly Jessica Drew Margo
kest spectacularly Spider-Man and
Ezekiel Sims moves away forming a dolly
Zoom effect which also makes Miguel more
of a narcissistic front man that is
alienated from his Society vulture Looms
in a view behind Miguel and he doesn't
sense it which is a little detail
showing that he might not have Spider
Sense and he might have to force his
connection to the others with his
technological know-how as Miguel and
Gwen bicker on tamino's wings he layers
over a thicker helmet to protect him
from the debris that he's flying through
to try to shake them off just a little
cool detail I noticed but then Miguel
says don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange with a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 this is Doctor Strange sounds
like he maybe shouldn't practice
medicine yes Earth 19999 has in the past
been the numerical designation for the
MCU films and shows but it was thrown
into question when Christine Palmer
called it 616 in Multiverse of Madness
but either way this proves that the MCU
and these animated films occupy the same
Multiverse because he's talking directly
about the multiversal crisis from
Spider-Man no way home Miguel says the
vulture has Hammer space and we see a
little editor's note text window reading
an infinite extra dimensional storage
area for cartoon Hammers and the like
referring to spider Ham's Mallet gift to
miles that he said could fit into any
pocket and not take a bitty space Lila
AKA lyrate life form approximation
return to the 2018 movie post credit
scene voiced by Greta Lee call for
backup what call Rebecca come on please
just call for you already called her but
I enjoyed that yeah in early theatrical
versions Lila does a fist bump but her
filter now makes him an Easter bunny
like nothing more than a vehicle for
Easter eggs and you know what he would
say to that I'm more than that I'm the
oldest Boy by the way Lord Miller
confirmed that the reason why there were
some changes from early theatrical
versions is that they had to send a
really early version of the movie to
French sensors for dubbing purposes and
that between that time and the worldwide
release they had a couple more tweaks
that they wanted to make I also just
noticed that Miguel tries to grab and
strangle Lila out of anger even though
she's a hologram the guy has rage issues
so he needs Spider-Man Jessica Drew
voiced by Issa Rae who is an outfit that
matches her red black and yellow color
scheme for the comics and yes she is
pregnant are you uh oh this we don't
know the sex yet my husband wants it to
be a surprise ah he's really corny but
so hot yeah we do not meet her husband
in this movie but I think it's gonna end
up being Shiro the Japanese Spider-Man
when the vulture Falls it's a beam and
it says which is Italian for night night
but Gwen kicks in a gear she closes her
eyes and she sees the spinning
helicopter blades as the same rotation
of her spinning drumstick in her fingers
and suddenly it's the same as just
getting into rhythm of playing her drum
kit and it is awesome we get this great
hero music but whenever Miguel jumps in
with his zigzag techno webs it's a
discorded Screech
but the three work together to stop the
helicopter from crashing yeah I think
it's a Banksy yeah they use post
Malone's vocal Cameo sound bite from the
2018 film yeah I think it's a Banksy
this webbed up helicopter is reminiscent
of a scene from the first Spider-Man
Insomniac game since that game is now
canon in this universe with Insomniac
Spiderman and the spider Society just
kind of fun to think about Gwen and the
Insomniac Peter maybe trading some
stories about stopping helicopter
crashes but Gwen reveals herself to her
father and the watercolor drips are just
gorgeous in the scene George is
surrounded by blood red paint seeing his
daughter as a murderer but behind Gwen
are the pink eye pieces of her mask
because that is all he can see her as
and as he reads her her Miranda writes
initially he cannot even look at her but
Miguel helps her out and he flips open
his wrist device and you can see his
current Universe says e65 but recent
visits e298 that's his home Universal
Nuevo York e1610 that's miles's universe
and e138 that is Hobie Brown's universe
so moving on to Miles parents meeting
with the guidance counselor his father
Jeff's badge now reads Morales whereas
in the 2018 movies last name was Davis
meaning he took his his wife's last name
in the comics they go into why Jeff and
Rio gave miles Rio's surname of Morales
Jeff didn't want miles to have his dad's
last name basically in Brooklyn there is
a mother shucker stand which is a real
life oyster and clam vendor in the New
York area the bodega security camera
lists the current date as July 11 2023
which explains why earlier one of the
vendors was Fanning himself with his hat
this would also mean miles goes to
school year round including the summer
at Brooklyn Visions Academy the register
in the bodega reads game over man and we
meet the spot Jonathan owned voiced by
Jason Schwartzman like Miguel O'Hara he
was drawn with deliberate blue animation
lines that were not erased because he is
another incomplete work in progress
inside the ATM that he tries to rob the
100 bills do not have Benjamin Franklin
face but the face of Alan Hawkins Sony's
animation supervisor as the spot
struggles with the machine the spots on
his leg accidentally slide over to the
machine and then pressing down with his
foot causes another hole to open and
that's what caused the machine to blip
back up into the crosswalk and yes the
spot calls it an ATM machine and a PIN
number both of which are redundant
phrases but as is Miles later when he
calls it chai T and in the bodega
display case are more Bagels the food
that first turned Jonathan own against
miles in miles sketchpad we say that
he's drawn past Spider-Man villains that
he's fought since the first film a
version of the Hammerhead AKA Joseph we
actually saw a beardless version of him
in the mugshot wall in the 2018 film a
version of Frogman and the Beetle and
then Grizzly and then at the end of this
miles's punch goes through the spot and
he punches himself we also see miles
suit design include the notes ABS no abs
and when we see it may selling her house
and moving the realtor was Adeline
Watson who is the mother of Mary Jane
Watson we see miles hosting jeopardy
with some fun categories swinging in the
rain arachnidiums Spider Sense and
Sensibility the Wide Web world and whip
it we also learned that he adores baby
powder which he had to apologize for
which seems like a reference to the
Johnson Johnson settlement over
cancer-causing baby powder we see the
video has over 10 million views but
somehow 69 million downvotes for the
comet saying old Spider-Man did need
baby powder even those Peter Parker told
miles to use baby powder you're going to
want to use baby powder in the soup and
then miles growing a mountain Dash leads
him to make a second apology video which
has over 11 million views but 70 million
downvotes and the top comment is I heard
it was made from actual spider legs
though for real 1610 Jay Jonah Jameson
broadcast from a show called Triple J
today and Miles mom says I hear that
Miss Spider-Man is Puerto Rican no he
seems more Dominican to me this could
actually be foreshadowing how the actor
who voices Earth 42 miles Jarrell Jerome
is Dominican and I love how wind miles
disrobes to his suit whereas before his
neck was Bare now the suit covers his
neck and his parents toss the couch into
the air and it never comes down because
this is all a fantasy miles updates the
no expectations are from the 2018 film
to now include Gwen Peter B Parker Aaron
and his Prowler form spider ham Noir and
Penny just text crack two this is
importage and fourth Kent and important
and Jeff C's response dots there's
bubbles now hold on soon after this
miles in the spot will be covered in
bubbles and suds in the car wash but
first they fly past Rio and Chef outside
the window in Miles Stags a goose and
from that car wash they land in the fall
party that is the Hipster coffee shop
that people were lining up for at the
beginning of the 2018 film with the suds
inside of it it now becomes a literal
foam party and the Hipster behind the
spot is eating would you know it a bagel
as the two tumble through the next
portal one of the bagels follows them
after webbing up the spot miles Pats his
head and we see the text good cow this
would be after miles thought the spot
was a cow thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video watching stuff
frame by frame is great but it can also
be really rewarding to zoom out and look
at things like story pacing and
character development for a movie you
can just let it play out but when you're
the target of analysis it's better to
get some help from better help
regardless if you have a clinical mental
health issue like depression or anxiety
or if you're just going through a hard
time therapy can give you some tools to
approach your life in a very different
way with better help you can tap into a
network of over 30 000 licenses and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues it's easy to
sign up and get matched with a therapist
there's a link in my description it's
betterhelp.com new rockstars to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with the
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit in
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for free without
stressing about insurance or who's in
your network or anything like that you
can always benefit from talking to
somebody and getting things off your
chest so if you're struggling consider
online therapy with better help click
the link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com do rockstars clicking
that link helps support this channel but
it also gets you 10 off your first month
of better help when miles returns to his
dorm room he stops to let the pigeons
fly past like at a crosswalk remembering
from the 2018 movie to waits around the
corner to avoid smacking into pigeons
his roommate ganki Lee is playing the
PS5 Spider-Man 2 video game on his wall
as the poster for soccer player Huang
Min Sun known for doing a Spider-Man
celebration when he scores and on the
wall is an insane Easter egg a New York
Bulletin front page reading hero or
Rogue with a photo of Daisy Ridley Quake
from Agents of Shield oh my God
suggesting that ages of Shield might be
Canon and at least this side of the
Marvel Multiverse and really let's just
assume all the Multiverse gunky says I'm
not your guy in the chair referencing
the MCU Ned who loved being Peter
Parker's guy in the chair and Jacob
battleland was totally cast with the
Ultimate Comics gunky Lee in mind now
gankili is voiced by Peter son director
of Pixar's Elemental movie that despite
initially falling short to Across the
spider-verse of the June 2023 box office
eventually went on to make a pretty
solid profit throughout the summer was
initially written off as a flop was
actually kind of a sleeper hit folks
these animators aren't really in
competition with each other they really
do lift each other up Rachel Dratch
voices a guidance counselor and says
can't have your cake and eat it too
messy big two cakes later buying two
cakes screws battles over because he
can't whip with both in his hands
there's a little character beat that I
love here I gotta get back to being a
great student so can we make this quick
okay yeah miles goes silent when his mom
looks at him and when his dad glares at
him he sits up straight two different
non-verbal parenting stares that tell
this kid everything he needs to know and
when they learn about his beat in
Spanish Rio snaps at miles make it a
little Puerto Rican flag the shame
draped in his Heritage the guidance
counselor says miles has a great story
to tell having a story at all seems
gross I love this line because it
foreshadows miles conflict with Miguel
later Miguel demanding that he follow a
cannon event blueprint and also this
idea that high school kids probably feel
annoyed nowadays and having to
encapsulate their whole existence into
some kind of story narrative or their
college applications it is pretty gross
miles wants to go to Princeton because
they are studying dark matter I could
help figure out how to travel to other
dimensions really this poor kid wants to
build a path to find his friends when
miles resumes his fight with a spot they
portal through the high school and they
pass this kid with glasses who later
shows up on the street the same kid with
a goofy smile from the 2018 movie who I
called a dumbass in my June breakdown I
think that was pretty unfair he's not a
dumbass he's a straight-up serial killer
and I hope he burns in hell they end up
with Jeff back in the alchemax site
where the final battle in the last movie
took place and Jeff has to make a leap
of faith but chicken's out
foreign
yes this is the same gag as miles
chickening out from his leap of faith
the first time in the 2018 movie The
Spot flinks three portals at Miles and
Miles rolls midair to dodge them
reminding us of Peter Parker's big move
in the 2002 film when he dodged Green
Goblins razors in the burning building
the spot Reveals His origin as the
creator of the outcome X collider device
in the 2018 film I ran a test on this
collider that brought a spider here from
another dimension oh my God that Earth
was about to bite Earth 42 miles who
later becomes a Prowler notice how he
has the same hair braids and unlike 16
10 miles it was out spray painting walls
this kid was actually in school at the
time he is gallon to our miles Goofus I
just think it's another clue that
Prowler miles is actually a destined
hero and not the villain that we think
he is at the end of the movie I also
like how the 2018 movie foreshadowed the
fact that the number 42 spider Came From
Another Dimension by having it randomly
glitch at times and yes we learned that
Jonathan own was the guy miles hit with
a bagel in the 2018 film at the Hudson
Valley outcome X lab one of our favorite
animation details from the past five
years led to one of the biggest
consequences and I love it the spot
kicking his own butt causes one eye hole
to shrink and when he first falls into
himself notice how he has no holes on
his body here first the spot 6 is set
into what looks like a 1940s animated
reality with visible Ben day Dots and a
woman with a polka dot blouse looking
like his skin is who attacks him
immediately next he appears into the
Lego verse earth13122 These Lego scenes
in this movie were actually animated by
14 year old Lego animator Preston mutaga
who is made a number of incredible Lego
versions of these scenes he was actually
emailed by the movie's producers to see
if he wanted to do these parts of the
movie and he did such a good job okay
then the spot looks into Miss chance
Bodega in Chinatown from the Venom
movies Earth 688 it is labeled and the
gum he takes is the Venom mint brand
which is the flavor I guess named after
Venom in this reality the spot says
power the Multiverse in the palm of my
hand of course a call back to Doc Ox big
line in the 2004 Spider-Man 2 the Power
of the Sun
in the palm of my hand which also got
called back in no way home and then we
briefly returned to the Lego verse with
another JK Simmons sound bite here
tomorrow morning Spider-Man page one
with a decent picture this time you're
absolutely right Boss shut up we see a
Daily Bugle on the wall reading doc Ox
still at large which seems like it was
from the 2004 Spider-Man 2 film and then
the other three Lego people in this room
that Peter passes are probably also the
daily beagle staff from the Remy era
films it looks like a Lego Betty Brant
there and then on the couch that looks
like Lego versions of Robbie and Hoffman
also you'll notice the text box of the
Lego verse is a red Lego brick okay on
to the rooftop party we see some kids
playing with teriyaki mon cards these
are the 1610 versions of Pokemon cards
miles has these floating around his room
later like Tobey Maguire Peter Parker
having to take the elevator in
Spider-Man 2 miles has to ride a crowded
subway train miles then hops onto the
track to quickly zap the villain to
armadillo and then he foils the thief
stealing Nikes and passes the mass
murderer I mentioned before also notice
this Abomination has a gross mild style
pubescent mustache Jeff Morales toasts
the mural of Aaron which miles probably
painted it's definitely up there
laughing at me right now up there in
retrospect makes it sound like Earth 42
is the up there that's the limbo
afterlife this movie ends in and Jeff
promises and I will always be here for
you and by here in Earth 42 it's the
same rooftop where Jeff is there just in
the form of a memorial mural miles
changes into his number 42 Jersey
matching his spider's number and yes I
always have to repeat everything the
number 42 references because if I don't
there's one commentary who's like oh
it's also a reference to this okay
number 42 yes it's Miles number is the
number the spider it's Jackie Robinson's
number it's The Hitchhiker's Guide
number aside from Jackie Robinson all
these numbers are just referencing each
other miles cake Rex Now read I'm not
proud Jeff and Rio complain that Genki
calls it by the first name so that later
when Gwen does it they totally cringe
miles refers to his friends Peter and
gwanda using Gwen's nickname that she
gave him in the first film and after Rio
corrected his Spanglish earlier notice
how he talks back now
break is that Spanglish
oh boy you're gonna get the chocolate so
Miles goes down to his room where boxing
gloves hang by the door again reminding
us of his boxing lessons with Uncle
Aaron in the punching bag that he's
gonna be tied up to at the end of the
movie there's also a Michelle Obama
Campaign sticker suggesting that in 1610
she was the Obama who held or at least
sought public office floating in this
room is the Amazing Fantasy number 15
comic that was altered slightly from the
2018 movie it's coming back from that
film and a mile shelf is his RC
spidermobile which 1610 Peter had a
life-size version of and above that
there is a photo of Miles dad Jeff and
Aaron that Jeff had on his phone
background and was also framed in
Aaron's apartment and on a shelf to the
left miles says this wooden moose this
is any strike for Gordon Miller's 2021
film Mitchells versus machines a very
very important totem to the Mitchell
Family in that film just watch it it's
so good now in my own Sketchbook he kept
a bus ticket stub Hudson Valley Explorer
Schenectady to Brooklyn Central this is
the bus ride home that they took after
Gwen saved them from Olivia Octavius so
basically Gwen keeps the photo miles
keeps the ticket stub so she's flattered
by this the two of them remember each
other the same way miles and Gwen swing
from the construction crane to
Construction crane kinda like Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man does in the climax
of the 2012 Amazing Spider-Man film and
as they thread the needle between the
buses notice how all the blocks are just
colored pink and teal Hues so Gwen's
colors are tinting this reality there's
a fun POV shot from the truck driver
miles swings on the right side reflected
in the mirrors and then we turn to the
right side mirrors as he flies behind
and the exclamation points from his
scream chase him like the ah from his
fall in the 2018 film and the woo in the
Final Act miles asks who's Miguel oh
he's like a ninja vampire Spider-Man but
a good guy a vampire good guy I'd make
good money to see that yeah it's kind of
a meta not too morbius the living
vampire fire a good guy vampire that
Sony hoped we would pay good money to
see twice miles stays behind Gwen
throughout this whole sequence hiding
his clumsy collisions and he's just
trying to come off as cooler and more
confident but really he's just copying
what Gwen does just not as well kind of
like how he hastily ties his web to his
ankle they pass a hot dog vendor and we
see the action word take on the hot dog
swipe and Miles whips money to the
vendor's chest if you look closely this
is an alternate universe 25 Bill Gwen
says like last week we had this mission
to some Shakespeare Dimensions yeah
Marvel actually published a book called
William Shakespeare's Avengers that
retells Avengers stories and I am in
pentameter and I love this little kid
who just mindlessly licks the window of
the train with a big smile it's so gross
it's kind of a callback to when miles
put his mouth on Aaron's window in the
2018 movie now Gwen plants a drone to
spy on the spot's apartment above it is
a billboard with a bagel all of it
always all over the place seven time
Tony Award winner which must be a Play
version of The Bagel themed multi-oscar
winning film everything everywhere all
at once and again the movie's animators
acknowledging The Bagel parallel with
Jonathan own there's also so this phone
number one
917-161-0616 917 the New York area code
1610 miles is Universe 616 the main
Marvel Universe and I also just chuckle
at decent view my favorite shot of the
film is Miles and Gwen looking out over
the city upside down from the
Williamsburg Bank building when Gwen
first walks upside down the sun
disappears briefly behind her and then
reappears it's just so beautiful the
artist added layers of hazy background
skyscrapers included some that are just
unfilled contour lines because these
Brooklyn and Chelsea kids can't really
imagine how far the city goes whereas
live action films use matte paintings to
try to look realistic here are the
painted backdrop is trying to look
intentionally painted and it's just
perfect for these characters Gwen and
Miles sit upside down whipping the
underside of the overhang and then as
they sit their hands and their legs must
just be sticky but as they hang upside
down you can see gravity tugging their
eyebrows and their cheeks and their
foreheads upward just such such good
attention to detail now Gwen says in
every other Universe Gwen Stacy Falls
for Spider-Man and in every other
universe
it doesn't end well yeah not only is she
referring to Earth 65 Peter's death as
the lizard she's also reported to the
universe where Gwen Stacy famously dies
in the death of Gwen Stacy art you know
Rio tells miles about the boys she
really worries about wherever you go
from here you have to promise to take
care of that little boy for me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from
and he never doubts that he is loved
it's so sweet and she's referring to him
obviously but she's using the third
person here which allows us to apply
this to Miles taking care of Earth 42
miles his multiversal brother to make
that boy feel loved too when miles
re-zips his pants back up I love how the
re-zip word bends and folds inward like
miles pants fly would on the way to
Owen's place there is this sign soda
it's a generic brand and inside his
whole filled apartment you can see a
certificate for Alco Max breakthrough of
the year with a hole on the o of own and
it's signed by a living arctivist we
actually see her in a photo with
Jonathan she stole his research his
spider containers are labeled Earth 42
that was the spider that bit miles rap
there's also 14512 that's pity Parker's
Universe 333 that's the universe of an
alternate Electro Maxwell Dylan there's
90214 that's Norris universe 19925
that's the universe supposedly written
by a bot and in 509 the universe of
Andros Stark miles jumps in after Gwen
in the portal tunnel and lands in Earth
50101 a cross between Mumbai and
Manhattan it looks amazing from above
its geography looks like the island of
Manhattan but Greener what we think are
the rivers are actually the city's lower
levels the artists designed Manhattan to
keep going down and down and down a
contrast from 1610 Manhattan that just
goes up and up and up in mombatten
instead of the trains running on top of
the tracks the cars hang from the rail
above them when miles falls through this
reality his animation style changes to
match it similarly you'll notice later
it becomes more 3D in Nueva York to
match Miguel O'Hara's design when miles
bumps into stuff here the action words
are all in Hindi and macbatten there's a
billboard for sacred Wars oh my God
could this be this universe is Avengers
Secret Wars is this all a sign this
animated Miles Morales or just some
Miles Morales is going to be in secret
Wars I swear to God it miles is it in
secret Wars I guess I'll still see it
but you know I want him to be in it
Professor Spider-Man India from Earth
50101 is voiced by Karen Sony AKA do
Pinder from the Deadpool films he spends
his web shooter from a spindle like a
yo-yo when he hits a spot in the back of
the head it makes a Hindi word which
kind of means bang or slam pavs Acrobat
like movement and the way he flattens
his feet is based on a 2 000 year old
martial art from the Indian region of
Kerala pav talks about drinking chai I
love chai tea what did you just say
I mean Steve bro you're saying DD yes
miles is so distracted if we're being
redundant that he spills the tea which
flows out onto the table spot says he's
on a journey of self-discovery and POV
calls him out for the Western cliche
referencing Eat Pray Love but this is
also something Jason Schwartzman did in
the Wes Anderson movie The Darjeeling
Limited so it's kind of a perfect
reference as they fight the spot we see
his dark matter has now filled in more
of his body so that he's gradually going
more from white to black the spot
activates the mumbatin collider and
Hobie Brown crashes it hobie's comic
book page actually shows his comic
moment when he told Green Goblin fish no
more speeches Norman I'm gonna kick your
ass hobie's electric guitar smashes
through the barrier and he advises miles
to use his whole Palms not just his
fingertips setting up miles Big Move
later it's suggesting that Hobie might
have a similar electricity coursing
through his body Hobie Brown's Body in
this movie was animated on threes with
his vest offset and his guitar is
animated on fours and his General
outline is animated on twos so they
actually separated different parts of
his body for an overall anarchical punk
rock aesthetic each of his guitar poses
are truly iconic poses is there's only
so many different frames this guitar can
be in and this shows how Hobie chooses
to be out of step with the other spider
people even more grounded in the source
medium Than Miles was and it shows miles
that there is another way to exist in
this Multiverse and arguably more
powerful way Hobie says I hate the am I
hate the PM hey hey I'm not a hero
calling yourself a hero makes you a
self-refologized and narcissistic oh
crap hike the PM is some Cockney
wordplay hating the time of day and the
Prime Minister and notice how he drags
his boot across an image of Kingpin was
Kingpin the prime minister of hobie's
reality I'm just curious to know what
their history was the aquamax building
collapses reigning Rebel on the city the
four leap into action pop sees his
girlfriend on a double decker bus on the
bridge recalling the MCU Peter Parker's
girlfriend MJ in danger on the double
decker bus and Far From Home everyone
gets saved but miles disrupted the Canon
event of Captain Singh's death causing
Dark Matter to consume the city Jessica
Drew arrives with a team to contain it
Ezekiel Sim Spider-Man with the
motorcycle jacket there's a curvy Spider
Woman there's also a super bulky variant
who might be spider Hulk and then this
armored one that's fight armor Mark III
and then we see Max born from earth2211
so on to Earth 928 Nueva York hobie's
color you'll notice now turns monotone
which always happens whenever he's not
really thrilled with his current
situation and just like before on the
bank roof miles looks out on the city
upside down he's actually ascending but
for him it feels like he's descending so
it's not a heroic rise it's more of a
plunge into hell for the character they
arrive and we meet Malala Windsor spider
UK from earth835 She's voiced by Sophia
Barclay she says anyone spoke the spot
it just asked if anyone else's jokes and
we see all these blue text boxes showing
everyone else's jokes C Spot Run x marks
a weird looking bad guy our search plan
is full of holes did he say quip or FIP
we need to run a spot check well
somebody got up on the wrong side of the
web this morning he could be in any hole
in the world puns on my weak spot he's
probably hiding out in some hole in the
wall hey way to put us on the spot mate
this search is starting to Peter out
there's also one in the background just
saying
which is kind of creepy also we see an
Alex Ross concept art Spider-Man Alex
Ross came up with this and it was later
used to inspire superior Spider-Man in
the comics as the camera Glides through
the main hall of the HQ we pass a black
and yellow spider armor Mark II sit on
the left Mary Jane Parker AKA
spinnerette from the 2015 limited run
renew your vows and her daughter Anna
May Parker spiderling there's a
steampunky looking one this is May
Riley's lady spider from Earth 803
there's a traffic cop Spider-Man there's
the bombastic Bag Man when Peter Parker
breaks into the Baxter building and puts
on a Fantastic Four costume and has to
put a paper bag over his head though
here it's just a Spider-Man suit we see
the Flash Thompson Spider-Man with the
Letterman jacket also spider wolf miles
passes Peter parked car of Earth 53931
he pulls up and inside of him there's
tarantula of Earth 1610a technically
these movies are set in 1610b Spider's
side of Earth 616 Last Stand of Earth 31
2500 Peter of earth13122 otherwise known
as the Lego Universe we saw earlier Andy
Samberg voices Ben Riley AKA The Scarlet
Spider of Earth 94 Taryn killum voices
web Slinger from earth31913 and his
horse Widow who also wears masks miles
towards the anomaly villains we see a
grizzly several doc Ox a moose Cheerio
and a Mysterio in the video game section
we see the Insomniac Spiderman of Earth
1048 that's the universe of the
PlayStation games he asks are you
talking to me and that's the voice of
Yuri lowenthal who voices Peter Parker
in those games beside him is the Green
Goblin from the 1982 Spider-Man Atari
game and then this blue pixelated video
man he's from Spider-Man and His Amazing
Friends he has the ability to suck
people into video games there's a
villain named typeface who says go to
helvetica Spider-Man and all of his
words appear in different typefaces and
Spider-Man appears in the Sam Raimi era
logo font miles meets Donald freaking
Glover as Prowler hey
yeah
it's rude to stare call that one myself
I slipped Hobie claims he caught him and
Glover says I slipped now remember
Glover played Aaron Davis in the MCU in
Spider-Man Homecoming in 2017 and cameo
in the 2018 spider-verse film from his
scene in ABC's Community when Troy wears
Spider-Man PJs either way seeing
cartoons with live action just more
likely that we're gonna get live action
Miles Morales and the fact that Hobie
caught him again there's more to hobie's
backstory that I look forward to seeing
to in the next movie miles bumps into
Margo Kess AKA spider bite from Earth
22191 she's voiced by a manless Stenberg
right away you can see a shared Spider
Sense between them later when they part
ways they're definitely flirty there
some real chemistry so if things don't
work out with Gwen I think these two are
gonna end up together and margot's real
home she has his poster we be Incognito
with a guy Fox logo so a version of the
hacker group Anonymous but I just got
this listen closely here
here is better it's implied that Margo's
parents are fighting all the time and
she comes here to escape so sad as they
enter Miguel's lab notice how Hobie
swipes stuff off the wall so that later
he can engineer his own Multiverse watch
for Gwen there's also all these
futuristic versions of tech from
villains Miguel is defeated including
the claw of a Prowler the arms of Doc
Ock the glider Green Goblin but most
importantly in this room you'll see in
the background Miguel is totally
building his red and white 2099 suit
from the game Miguel launches into his
big explanation of everything first
depicting all of reality with his
glowing white Vine with branches which
is definitely supposed to look like the
sacred timeline of the MCU so definitely
this spider-verse is connected to the
live-action MCU but over this white Vine
we see straight red lasers beaming out
to represent the spider-verse and Miguel
refers to it as a web of life and
Destiny which is the term for the comics
or in his words arachno humanoid poly
Multiverse all the nodes we see
represent Canon events in the first one
we see six different comic moments when
a spider bite occurred including this
early one where Peter wears the yellow
vest but behind that are various moments
where Peter and Mary Jane kissed and we
see Kirsten dunce Mary Jane kissing Toby
McGuire Peter in the Rain from the 2002
film but then to the left the next node
Miguel refers to is very very bad
showing six moments the Venom symbiote
overtook Eddie Brock in the comics one
of these witches is when Toby Maguire
Peter pulled the Symbiote off himself in
Spider-Man 3. Miguel singles out event
ASM 90 which is a nod to Amazing
Spider-Man number 90 in which George
Stacy saves a kid this is the same
Comics art here during Spider-Man's
fight with Doc that ends up taking
George's life miles turns over to a
parallel moment a projection of Andrew
Garfield Peter Parker crying over the
body of Dennis Leary Captain Stacy from
2012's Amazing Spider-Man film when
George was killed by Rhys eichmann's the
lizard other Canon events that we see
are implied to be the Spider-Man no more
step that Hobie Brown sees himself in
that's from Amazing Spider-Man number
50. Jessica Drew trapped into the rubble
that's from The Amazing Spider-Man
number 33 we actually saw Tom Holland
Peter Parker going through this and
homecoming and then this wedding issue
The Amazing Spider-Man Annual number 21
that Peter B Parker sees himself in
meanwhile Gwyn seems to be looking at a
death of Gwen Stacy issue which for her
must be pretty haunting we see the Cliff
Robertson Uncle Ben dying from the 2002
film and Toby McGuire Peter Parker
crying over him to the right of that is
the animated Spectacular Spider-Man
voiced by Josh Keaton in this movie as
he was in the Animated Series the moment
his Uncle Ben died and then on the far
right is Uncle Ben's death cut scene
from the PS4 game so Miles breaks free
and he runs for it Miguel alerts the
rest to all point to each other in the
classic Spider-Man pointing meme but
then Miguel says I own your miles icono
is Spanish for essentially God damn it
Max Bourne steps up to this awesome
looking Spider Woman Anya Corazon who
looks badass and she has that noticeable
d-ring on her belt some of you know what
that means there's also a Canadian
Spider-Woman chasing miles according to
production designer Patrick O'Keefe she
got her look from the 1972 Summit Series
hockey jerseys there's a stubby chibi
Spider-Man there's a cyborg Spider Woman
spider cat scratches up miles face it
costs up a web hairball its Tech is on
its tail there's a spider rex or pater
pitarker from Earth 66 it Tiss whips
miles toward camera fleeing the manga
Spider-Man and the bombastic Bag Man by
turning his back sideways and then
Spider-Man Unlimited from the 90s series
with his cape in the cafeteria you'll
notice they serve Miguel themed
hamburgers there's a spider monkey here
there's a Julia Carpenter Spider Woman
and then we get this moment and then I
looked at my
let me guess he died on the walls of
this therapy office is an ink blot test
that naturally looks like a spider
there's a diploma from ditko University
a Nadu Spider-Man co-creator Steve ditko
Miles ends up in a duel with web Slinger
on the count of three draw one get away
for three yeah I love all the aspect
ratio shifts to look like a Clint
Eastwood film Peter B Parker follows
them can you take a photo of this it's
her first Chase Mayday whips the button
to take the selfie miles passes
Charlotte Weber the sun spider who has
ehlers-danlos syndrome that affects her
joints and connective tissue she's a
wheelchair and crutches and she makes a
pun about crutches she's voiced by
Danielle Perez 1967 Spider-Man voiced by
yorman tacon tries to grab Miles but he
misses him because 67 Spidey is in 2D
and he flies right past him miles runs
through the strength and conditioning
gem with 90 Spider-Man animated versions
of the Sinister Six including a dock who
says hello Peter using Alfred Molina doc
Ox line from Spider-Man no way home
hello Peter
hi composer Metro Boomin cameos as one
of the spider people so after the chase
outside the building Peter B Parker
tries to get miles to hold Mayday saying
he's the reason he had her reminding us
of that 2018 film with Peter B Parker
had to split with MJ because he didn't
have kids but upon meeting Miles Morales
and seeing how cool of a hero he was he
asked himself not all the kids Miguel
chases miles on a skybound bullet train
after kicking Miguel breaking some of
the glass off just like it did in the
big heroic Montage in the first film
miles ends up back in the tunnel on
someone else's car what's up man wait a
minute circular glasses I knew you
that's my Nemesis all smiling dumbass I
hope the moon explodes when you get to
it at one point on Miles lunge a frame
flashes from an animation storyboard
cell including some artist notes
Imperial Violet and crimson red this
instructs the artist what ink color to
use to fill in the character those
shades are the specific shades of red
and indigo for Miguel's suit and at one
point miles glitches into his
store-bought costume from the 2018 movie
that he bought from Stan Lee this is
just an insane sequence and I love it
Miguel leans in Colleen miles a mistake
it gets darker and darker as they leave
Earth stratosphere here to Inner Space
miles uses hobie's advice and Uncle
Aaron's advice a similar movie used on
Kingpin putting a hand on his shoulder
full Palm electrocution bugging out
Miguel's Tech suit to supercharge it
miles gets away Dives back down and
sneaks past Margot to the go home
machine but since it reads spider DNA
the screen reads Earth 42 telling us
that miles is not going home to 1610.
Peter B Parker puts Mayday down to sleep
and we see that she wears spider ham PJs
MJ and him talk about how there's no
Playbook on being a parent you just have
to make adjustments at halftime which
definitely feels like a meta nod to this
story's two-part structure with beyond
the spiderverse where at halftime
currently spider-verse is going to be
the second half miles swings through
Earth 42 and there are some Sinister Six
cartel red flags if you look closely
there's a sign for vulture Telecom and
Electro 2G cell service on the rooftop
later there's science for scorpo which
might be an alternate universe Oscorp
there is a sign for a rhino Casino
Sandman slots and Resort a vote for
Craven sign and what I thought might be
a shocker s but that might just be for
Scorpio Earth 42 Times Square has w W's
alternate M Ms which also have the
colors reversed from the regular in
peanut m m instead of Forever 21 there's
never 21 which makes me really worried
about the life expectancy of this
reality miles passes images of Noir and
ham and Penny and the train tracks turn
into giant Olivia Octavius arms and
mouse returns to his room but whereas
before his outfit was blue and red now
the colors are green and purple which
are prowler's colors we also see
blueprints of the prowler gauntlets on
his shelf now it may just be the
lighting but it kind of looks like Rio
has green eyes in Earth 42 instead of
the other reality where they're brown
miles a poster above his bed is oshami
on green instead of Sashimi on red as it
is in 1610 Rio asks can you shoot silk
out of your culito which is Spanish for
little butt and Miles says I had a
nightmare about that once but no and
since this is connected to the MCU
Multiverse of Madness dream walking
rules do apply in which dreams are you
in another universe and both America
Chavez and MCU Peter Parker speculated
about alternate Spider-Man shooting webs
out of their butts so you know it's
somewhere out there there's one who is I
also like how miles demonstrates his web
shooting abilities with sad little whip
the Whip miles realizes he was sent to
the wrong universe and here in Earth 42
uncle Aaron is still alive and he comes
through the door
[Music]
uncle Aaron
hey there it is hey is romantic advice
in 2018. Aaron mentions miles took his
braids out signaling that there is
another miles in this universe the
rooftop mural is now a memorial for Jeff
Morales and in the upper corners of that
mural pacelli and Bendis for Sarah
pacelli and Brian Michael Bendis
creators of the Miles Morales character
Aaron's phone lights up and he gives
miles a bit of side eye meaning his
phone text came from Earth 42 miles and
Aaron knows something's weird here miles
gets ko'd and his Spider Sense never
goes off maybe because he can't sense
himself especially if that variant
doesn't have spider powers which is kind
of like glitches his spidey sense out
miles wakes up tied to the punching bag
that he and Aaron needs to train on and
the one that he tied Peter B Parker up
to the colors in this room are red and
blue which is the aura that Miles color
changed to from purple and green to red
and blue when 1610 Peter looked at him
so I think that is a good sign for Earth
42 miles and Aaron and the red and blue
mix on Miles face forming purple in the
middle something he has in common with
his variant on the TV we hear JK Simmons
as Jason Davidson talking about the
Sinister Six cartel and now no one will
try to stop him I think Aaron and
Prowler miles are trying to stop them
and that spider was just about to bite
this miles I think he's a good kid also
known as miles shoes miles started tying
his shoes in the 2018 film to show his
maturity but when he's tied up to
Aaron's punching bag he's back to his
shoes being untied he famously wears Air
Jordan once red and white with a black
swoosh remember that Genki stole from
him but Earth 42 miles wears ones with
alternate black colors but the film does
not end on the miles is it ends with
Gwen Stacy's drum solo just like it
began and now we see her assembling
Peter B Parker made a Hobie Brown pav
Margot and returning for the first film
Penny ham and Noir her final line is
yes she couldn't fit him with her own
band since she started her own her
opening monologue and this closing
monologue here are part of one speech
this is her pitch to them to help her
save her best friend to join her on this
apology tour I want to thank Eric
Francisco Jordan Morris Gina ipolito and
Erica wusu for their research help on
this breakdown subscribe to all three
channels of the new rockstars Network
you can follow me at eavos follow me
rockstars thanks for watching I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]